israeli troops spent three weeks on the
ground in gaza but most of the damage
and the deaths during this conflict came
from the air in the form of rockets
fired by hamas militants and air strikes
from the Israeli military the targeting
and intelligence required for these
strikes often came from unmanned aerial
vehicles known as UAVs or drones these
drones can also see ballistic launchers
and things like that you can see
everything basically they can see from
altitude of 6,000 feet from a soldier to
a rifle to a vehicle Daniel a Shah is
the deputy CEO of Aeronautics the 700
person private defense technology firm
that's focused almost exclusively on
drones we are selling more UAVs numbers
of platform more than anybody else in
this country the company share of the
domestic drone market is less than ten
percent but marketing to this country's
military forces often guarantees success
elsewhere this local market
unfortunately is battlefield whenever
you are combat-proven here in Israel you
have a stamp of quality and then it's
easy to convince international customer
that this is a local proven solution
ninety-five percent of the companies two
hundred million dollars in annual
revenues comes from customers on five
continents thanks to firms like
Aeronautics Israel's recently overtaken
the u.s. in UAV export numbers and this
country of 7 million people is now the
world's sixth largest arms exporter
overall I tell my students that Israeli
used to be known ones for exporting
oranges now it's exporting military
technology most israeli men like 25-year
navy veteran isha serve in the country's
military at some point or other this
means the defense and technology sectors
and consequently the entire israeli
economy benefits from a massive
workforce of ex-military personnel a lot
of buildup of knowledge know-how and
worker skills come from people serving
in the Israeli Defense Forces that has
been an excellent school for many
workers close links between the military
and defense companies here have been
crucial to developing new weapon systems
and growing these businesses how often
is it
in conversations with the Israeli
military that these ideas come up but
daily basis daily base you're talking to
them every day every every every day we
are meeting them in you know it's a
small community Aeronautics may have
indirectly profited from Israel's many
conflicts but the company like many
others here says it would rather see all
its technology used for peaceful
civilian purposes